You think you look strong you're
just a cheap knock-off. Oh no no
i'm the upgrade
Welcome to herogasm everyone this
will be my full video for the boys season three
episode six obviously it was the hero gasm episode
but that was only part of the episode there were
so many crazy moments so many easter eggs so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes and just careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet but the title
of episode 6 was hirogasm it's a reference to the
comics event and it was a little bit different
from the comics version it was like a toned-down
version but it was still almost as crazy the
version in the comics is meant to be like this
annual retreat for superheroes is basically them
doing like the worst version of spring break most
degenerate version of spring break you've ever
seen but the version on the tv show they just
turned into like this crazy underground party that
was hosted by superheroes that had moved around
a different location since the 50s which was
started by soldier boy and stormfront and i love
the idea that someone is patriotic as soldier boy
is as much as he thinks about that because he was
created during world war ii just like stormfront
started herogasm with liberty who was stormfront
herself just using a different name like nowadays
people probably wouldn't care about that as much
but he was literally sleeping with the enemy
like they fought on opposite sides of world war
ii he's more thick brained than an anime character
but the actual episode starts with a deep doing
a parody of the gal gadot imagine video which you
all probably remember it got dunked on so hard and
rightfully so because it was one of the cringiest
videos ever and obviously the version that they do
on the boys is meant to be the cringiest video
you've ever seen in for the episode they got a
bunch of different celebrities to do parody cameo
scenes for it it was patton oswalt who also did a
cameo scene during season two as the voice of the
deep's gills it was a train because he's doing all
kinds of cringy stuff this season josh gad mila
kunis and ashton koocher that was pretty weird
elizabeth banks kumail non gianni aisha tyler who
actually hosted the boys after show during season
two rose byrne and black noir pulled up the rear
holding up the car because either can't talk or
he won't talk we saw what happened to him in the
flashbacks he got super injured so that could have
hurt his vocal cords but it is possible that he
can't talk he's meant to be a little bit different
than the comic book version of black noir like
without getting into spoilers about his secret
identity there's meant to be like a big twist with
his character that you don't find out about to
like the very end of the comic story and they've
changed that for the tv show he's not meant to be
like the comic book version but there are easter
eggs for the big twists with black noir in the
comics they just played in a different way in more
of a moon knight kind of alternate personality way
which i'll get to in a second because that was a
big deal like they went full moon knight during
this episode with homelander with a dissociative
identity how many other personalities you got
inside there homelander also one of the details
that i loved about this like this is meant to be
a pretty authentic youtube player here they were
pretty accurate with it the deep is also using
it to sell his merch his tell-all book about the
church of the collective title deeper gotta sling
that merch the whole reason why vaugh creates
more superheroes is to create more merchandising
opportunities but that's until recently when stan
edgar says no we're not going to do that anymore
we found a better way to make money with this
compound v the reason why homelander freaks out
when he sees the footage of soldier boy isn't
because of his secret power because he doesn't
know about that yet the real reason he's worried
is because he thinks it's going to be this big pr
nightmare and blow back on the company if the
world finds out the supervillain that the news
has been hyping up recently winds up being their
actual sweetheart character that they've loved for
so long is the same basic idea with what's going
on with homelander on the side too like the world
learning about what he's really like which
starlight basically outs on her social media
at the end of the episode which is meant to be a
parallel for her during season one when she outed
what the deep had done to her she basically does
the exact same thing homelander also references
black noir being on soldier boy's payback team
years ago thinking that he's more loyal to him
like more of a friend to him but then right
after that black noir rips his tracker out so
that voc can't track him probably so that he
can go to ground and we'll find out what his
relationship with soldier boy really was that long
ago the tornado twins tried to throw him under the
bus when soldier boy confronted him about what
happened with the russians but i think the idea
is that he wasn't ultimately responsible black
noir is just trying to be practical like oh i'll
take my tracker out so i can go to ground
and nobody can drag me but soldier boy was
not wrong when he basically said that he's been
vaught's patsy this whole time like he said the
body cam on him that stan edgar has been using to
monitor everything that's been going on on the dl
the other funny moment here with ashley like there
are a couple funny moments with ashley during the
episode but she's actually worried for a hot
second about homeland or actually killing her
like she thinks it could be a possibility because
she realizes that the deep is totally incompetent
like she's worried that the deep is going to mess
this up and home later will come back and kill her
then they have all these captain america avengers
style jokes with soldier boy acclimating to modern
society the same way that captain america
did during the avengers movies like his
version of the beginning of the winter soldier
movie with them clowning on captain america
internet bluetooth those aren't real words you're
just making those up the whole joke about them not
having the oriental sauce is a big rick and morty
szechuan sauce joke if you don't know about the
szechuan sauce incident that was actually a big
deal a couple years ago mcdonald's used to make
the sauce when the animated mulan movie came out
many many years ago during the 90s this is branded
tie-in they stopped making it pretty quickly
after that like way back in the 90s long time ago
but recently rick sanchez yelled about it in a
rick and morty season 3 episode and as a result
set off this huge craze and mcdonald's tried
to bring the sauce back as a limited time event
it turned into a huge debacle it was nuts i
think i even made a video about it a couple
years ago like that's how big a deal it was when
soldier boy jokes that they won d-day back during
world war ii because they were high on bennies
in snorts a bunch of them he's talking about
just regular amphetamines because back then they
were still legal and the military gave them to
soldiers to pop like candy just to keep them alert
during battle like it was actually a real thing
they had this running joke about soldier boy
giving off this low-level radiation as part of
a side effect of his power it's basically like
a nuclear level power like a small nuclear bomb
that goes off every time he sets off his ability
and the more agitated he gets throughout their
conversation the higher the level of radiation he
gives off so he just keeps measuring him like oh
man this is getting kind of bad here there's also
this whole running subplot with his ptsd because
every time he hears a russian song he kind of
blacks out like he has ptsd and he winds up
losing control of his ability and claiming that
he doesn't remember what happened like he tells
butcher later wait what just happened right after
he gets done leveling the entire hero gasm house
huey also sees this weird residue on his finger
i think that's meant to be a weird side effect
of the temporary compound v because earlier they
teased that it might have some weird side effects
and he is an addict so i think that's just
going to get worse and worse and worse for him
then because his abilities have worn off they
have this big joke about him not being able to
lift soldier boy's shield that's also meant to
be a bit of a backdoor captain america easter
egg because vibranium captain america shield is
meant to be virtually weightless and soldier boy's
shield is made by vaught just out of regular
metal so it's super heavy they make their deal
with him to kill homelander soldier boy i've
come to bargain again their side of the deal
is just helping him find all the members of the
payback team so he can kill them black noir is
probably going to be one of the hardest ones for
him to find just because he ripped his tracker out
they set up the whole thing with kimiko's popsicle
the question on it why did the photo go to jail
the answer is because he was framed because
picture framed haha yeah like very funny joke
but later she winds up using that popsicle to stab
the hell out of little nina's men the whole thing
with little nina is that she's trying to force
frenchie to come back and be her lap dog and just
do whatever she says so that's why she's captured
both of the girls and are threatening them but the
big reveal here is that kimiko realizes that she's
always been a violent person it had nothing to do
with a compound v like that's not what made her
violent that's meant to be a parallel for huey's
big reveal at the end of the episode where he
reveals that he was always kind of resentful
of starlight for being the one with superpowers
and him being so weak then another deep's video
was supposed to be like the cringiest thing during
the episode but also a train's whole fake campaign
here about hyping up his african ruse is also
meant to be like the cringiest video you've ever
seen even ashley is like oh my god the overlay
here vaught images is just their version of getty
images pretty much all the tv networks inside
the boys universe are vac controlled networks
too so like vox soul is meant to be a reference
to the soul network which is a real life network
bhavat owns hundreds of tv networks all the
new shows that they go on even the one later
during the episode that's controlled by vaude so
they just control what people hear what they see
there's this real interesting thing going
on with ashley's character too she kind of
loses it on a train and i believe this is
the first time she stood up so brazenly to
a person with superheroes on the seven so i think
the idea is that this will continue but she does
look like she's gonna crap her pants the minute he
leaves the room this is also meant to set up that
moment with huey and a train where he apologizes
for killing his girlfriend and then later himself
winds up killing blue hawk for revenge even
though they're being kind of ambiguous with the
way the a train lied down there had that hard
episode i think he'll be fine it's just that
he's sinking a little bit lower and lower like
things will get worse for him as time goes on
before they get better i'd make more jokes about
what blue hawk was getting up to at that party
before a train took him out but the video would
probably get demonetized even talking a little
bit about some of the stuff that happened at
herogasm would probably get the video demonetized
the other really cool thing that they did in the
episode is they have this scene where homelander
hallucinates talking to himself in the mirror but
the way they played they play kind of like a moon
knight scene as if this is dissociative identity
that he has inside him that's been around this
whole time since he was a kid because when he's
talking to this alternate personality he says
what happened when we used to get thrown
in the bad room i used to take care of us
like this has been happening since he was a little
kid so just like moon knight he developed these
dissociative identities or at least this one i
don't know if there's others inside there when
they were a little kid but it sounds like it's
the other personality who's the violent one and
the one who's controlling the body right now is
just like the normal one who's a little bit meeker
like he's the steven grant and the one in the
mirror is the jake lockley version of homelander
i think this is meant to be a sly wink at the
comic book story line because in the comics
the difference was there was an actual clone
of homelander without getting completely into
spoiler territory for the comics because they're
not doing this on the tv show what they've done
with that copy of homelander on the tv show is
they said that it's actually dissociative identity
so in the comics there's this copy of homelander
who does all the terrible stuff that homelander
gets blamed for when really we find out that
homelander is actually meant to be like a normal
person like he didn't do any of the crazy stuff
that people thought that he did it was actually
the copy pretending to be him the whole time so i
think maybe on the tv show they might try to say
that it's the other personality who's done all the
really stuff that homelander is seen doing during
the show like which personalities can control
the body when he's doing all this crazy stuff
because it seems during their couple conversations
they have like the later conversation is silent we
don't hear what the personality is telling him in
the mirror it sounds like this other personality
at least in their first conversation wants to
take over the body wants them to become like
the craziest possible version of homelander they
could become so that might wind up being like a
final season thing where the crazy homelander
personality takes over the body kind of like
the moon knight tv show where jake lockley
takes over the body at the end of the series
post all your theories in the comments below
though do you think that was an actual alternate
identity inside the mirror or do you think they're
trying to say something else is going on here back
with soldier boy they have him watching this funny
old 80s movies that he made with the payback team
just complaining about his teammates there's also
a wilhelm scream in there too it's like the 80s
version of a dawn of the seven type of movie that
vought used to make they have him make a bunch of
awkward cosby jokes because obviously he's been
gone for like 30 plus years so he doesn't realize
what's actually happened to cosby in real life
he even makes a joke about cosby making strong
drinks which was all about what cosby got blamed
for all the things that he was on trial for that
he did to these women then the whole thing with
soulja boy talking about how he wanted sons
there's this crazy theory that he actually might
be the genetic father of homelander so the whole
idea with homelander being created on the show
is that he didn't have a traditional father or
a traditional mother he was basically created in
a petri dish then they use artificial insemination
to just have a woman carry him to term and because
he's meant to be a literal upgrade and they used
soldier boy as a template for homelander the
biological material like the sperm that they use
actually came from soldier boy so soldier boy
would literally be his father there are a couple
references to that later in the episode when they
actually duke it out and that was a great part of
the episode too when they all just had their big
battle royale at the end of the episode but that's
what homelander is talking about when he says i'm
the upgrade to you like he is metaphorically and
literally an upgrade like vaught literally tried
to upgrade their compound v when they created him
the whole reason that soldier boy refuses to tell
the other boys though about what happened with his
explosion in midtown it's just him not wanting
to admit his own ptsd problems like he hates
being weak and he makes fun of other men saying
that they're not manly men so he doesn't want to
acknowledge any of the mental problems that he's
having that's probably also going to get worse too
like he'll keep blacking out and losing control
of his power then they're pretty clear on what's
going on with this whole victorian newman scene
where she comes clean to starlight about popping
everyone's heads she basically tries to offer her
a deal just like the boys made with soldier boy
like it's just as bad a deal like she's being
just as dirty as the other guys she wants to
get rid of homelander too but she's willing to be
really bad to do it even though she does threaten
starlight's life like you see her nose bleed
like she was getting ready to pop her head like
she was kind of squeezing a little bit she doesn't
actually want to kill starlight she's just trying
to say that if you tell everyone about me i will
definitely try to kill you even though starlight
came clean at the end of the episode she did not
mention victoria newman either so victoria newman
still in the clear right now people still do not
realize that she's a secret superhero then there's
so many things that we can say about this herogasm
scene like there are a couple different scenes
at herogasm like you have starlight herogasm then
you have huey butcher soulja boy herogasm but sort
of setting up all the different conflicts that
happen at this big event mother's milk explains
how soulja boy actually killed his family because
we've seen a couple flashbacks this season they
were collateral damage from one of soldier boy's
takedowns of a couple unrelated car thieves he was
basically doing the same thing you saw homelander
doing during the opening scene of season one like
he just punts that dude to some other person's
car like a block away not even bothering to turn
around to look to see the dude land like he just
punted him and then just continued talking to the
camera pretty much all superheroes are like that
that's what starlight is talking about at the end
of the episode all these superheroes they don't
care about you in homelander he's the worst but
when they get to herogasm it's a big flash from
the past because love sausage answers the door
he was the same dude that mother's milk almost got
killed by during season 2 with his power that's
why he freaks out so bad and they reveal in the tv
show universe it's mother's milk who gives him the
love sausage name in the comics though he always
had the love sausage name and you can freeze frame
like every single frame that happens at this house
like all over the place everywhere your eye is
even though there are many many superheroes all
over the place wearing versions of their costumes
in various states of undress i think they're all
meant to be versions from the comics but some of
them you do recognize from either previous seasons
or from previously on this season like the ant-man
parody hero termite from that super opening
scene in episode one he's also here r.i.p to
him because homelander literally just squashes him
with his boot r.i.p to mother's milk's clothing he
gets someone's giant load blown all over him like
everything that happens at this house is just so
gross it's gonna take him like an entire year and
a lot of therapy to feel clean again after that
i already talked about the big soldier boy and
stormfront joke i started this back in 1952 with
this liberty character she was such a firecracker
totally not knowing that that was actually
stormfront an actual nazi and remember he fought
during world war ii for the americans the other
funny easter egg you may have noticed here too if
you've been watching umbrella academy is huey's
wearing a footloose t-shirt and during season 3
episode 1 of umbrella academy they actually do the
kenny loggins dance using the same song from the
footloose movie umbrella academy has nothing to do
with the boys it's just a funny coincidence that
he's wearing the t-shirt and that ears on the same
day i already explained all the blue hawk stuff
but then they pay off the joke about the deep
getting it on with fish obviously with an octopus
this time also paying off the joke from earlier
this season like they have all these jokes about
the deep doing it with fish which is meant to be a
big aquaman joke people making jokes about aquaman
doing it with fish like peacemaker had a bunch of
those kinds of jokes but because this is the boys
and this is herogasm like they literally have him
do it like he literally shows up with an octopus
on his junk the funny thing is too when the house
winds up blowing up later because of soldier boy's
power he's running away with the octopus still
alive in a bag yelling at it like they're yelling
at each other we also find out that huey's power
can teleport other people too in just like him it
only teleports organic matter so starlight winds
up naked too it seems like for now though because
of his big revelation that they're broken up but i
think they ultimately kind of want to be hopeful
with those two characters because huey's meant
to be so innocent on the show but they have this
whole thing with him using the temporary compound
v so i think it's probably going to be a while
but eventually they'll probably get back together
when soldier boy is taking out the party they
also reveal that his real name is ben we don't
know what his last name is they did show his vap
file in episode one but a lot of the details were
blurred out like it wasn't quite high-res enough
to see everything on that file the idea is that
originally he started out as this common criminal
that found in a prison they just took him and used
him for experiments with compound v and that's
how he became soldier boy it's meant to be a big
parody on captain america because obviously steve
rogers was meant to be like the best person in the
program whereas soldier boy was just like a common
criminal that they found in prison that day then
obviously probably one of the best parts of the
episode is the homelander battle royale so there
are a couple different parts of this fight here
you have homelander versus soldier boy where they
go at each other and they kind of talk it back
and forth like you're just a cheap knockoff of me
no i'm the upgrade then you have homelander versus
butcher with him just completely losing it and i
love the way that home later reacts to all the
temporary compound v powers like what did you do
you're cheating you're cheating the deal's off
they almost have him dead to rights but like i
said homelander is so much more powerful
than everyone else that it takes all them
to hold him down and they still can't keep him
down permanently like he takes off and escapes
you also have to remember that because maeve
was the one that was giving them the temporary
compound v and now she's under lock and key
like they have her at this special retreat
under lock and key they can't get more temporary
compound v so they're going to be out of powers
pretty soon then the other biggest reveal at the
end of the episode is starlight using her social
media to reveal the truth about everything that
vox been doing what homelanders been doing what
soldier boy was doing this whole time she reveals
the truth about all superheroes not really caring
about people at all the funny connection to thor
love and thunder in the marvel universe right now
is that gore is going around killing all the
gods in the marvel universe because they're
terrible people and they don't care about any of
their subjects it's the same basic principle with
superheroes on the boys they don't care about
anybody but themselves and if you look at all
the comments on her social media post here while
it's happening it seems like most of her followers
believe what she's saying so we'll see what kind
of blowback there is in the public in next week's
episode but i think they're planning on doing at
least like four or five seasons maybe a little
bit more of the boys like they'll keep going
so i don't think this is meant to be like the
end of the boys show but they are making it feel
like they're heading towards an end game type of
scorched earth scenario so it'll be interesting
to see how they swerve on that in the season
finale but if there's any other easter eggs in the
episode that you spotted that i didn't talk about
in the video just write them below in the comments
and my full episode 7 video will post next week
everyone click here for my brand new thor love
and thunder trailer video thor vs the celestials
and click here for my full ms marvel
episode 3 video in shangshi easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!